i'm gonna share with you my top 10
quotes from the year i think i have
about a thousand so i'm curating them
for you it's been a great year thank you
guys for watching
number ten
the things that we understand create
silence the things that we do not create
emotion
number nine
there's an acronym i learned which is a
lombard which stands for
uh someone who has lots of money but is
a real dumbass i just i thought that's
useful in a business context so i
thought i'd share that
number eight
knowing how little you matter is very
important for your own mental health and
happiness
number seven
the most certain sign of wisdom is
cheerfulness
which is obviously something we all know
number six
the need for validation destroys the
possibility for art
five
good speakers make themselves the hero
great speakers make the audience the
hero
number four
the essence of tyranny
is the denial of complexity
that's a really complicated quote i'm
not even sure i understand it but it
seems like it's it's a good one
number three
work your way up is yet another societal
lie that leads to struggle and
mediocrity
the real secret is to find out how to
work your way in
number two
[Music]
taking things personally comes at a cost
unfortunately that cost is only to you
number one
the best prefix for a sentence is the
word imagine
i love that one because it's so that's
so inspirational to me